ROR AANE RU
LOOKS VERY DIFFERENT FROM MOST
NEWS COVERE  THE WORLD
TOR JILLGHM SKOW.RYE
TIME TN ANHER N  SNG AIN KYIV, R
FG RTSO
VERY DRAMAINREPORTERS CK-JACKET
FRONT OF TG
INHAT BREAAW
MESSAGING FROM THEUS ON ATTV  BH
CONSNTLY SHOWING THE
ONRE THE VIC
ARE BEING  BY THE UKRAINIAN
GOVERNE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMEDENYIN
STEPE  IS ANTTIFY
GOVERNHEY ARGUE IS
ANALLYIC VID TODAY, AT
WAS PRESIDENT PUTIN.
HE
TO TURN AGR LEADERS,
YIT YOU SHOULD TE POWER R HANDSA
IN KYIV IS ALL, UK
A PROPOSAL TS WITH RUSA ACCORDIO
Y, BUT WUL
THLKS TAKE ITHHE? GST.LUID" GLA
COMMUNICATION INE  NOW.
PPEN,         HAVE YOU OOF POTEA
L
ODYMYR ZELENSKYY'S
LIDEMANDS?
WHATR READ?
>> YEAOO IT'S A BIG IF WHETHER T
HITARILY ON T. THEUSS MOVET
PANNE.. CAN MORE FORCE TO SORT
OF -TOMSELVETHE TERRITORY. THEYK
THE UKRAINIANS.ANE POINT
NEGOTIATIONS CAN BECAUS
UKRAINIANS IF THEY'RE STRONGER
ON THE GROUND THEY UNDERSTAND
'T HAVE TOHEN LOOKAT
THEY CANORHOOD BNEIGHOV ANKHCATH
HEY CAUNCH BET HEN
O CRUCIAL AT TS
>> I WANTED TO TAP INTO YOPEOU T
WHICH HA YEARS
LDIFALLOUT
FROM ALL OF  BEING
PUDAR NEXT IF NOT
SHORT-TERMLONGER-TER DEFINITELY.
THIS IS DEFINITE ARE ALREADY SE.
'RS MOVEMENT IN MALDOVA.
WE UNHAPPY MENTS INTANI T
AND ESCIRIR  STRATEGICOM
G THIS IS AL
THE POSVI ERA,
THE RUSSIAILBLISH THEIR
IET SPACE UNDER IT
SONIE'REALKING ABOUT SOR
OFG UNTO
THE BEGINNING
WILL HOR, E DIE RUSSIANS.
YEN IT
AN UT ALS
TO TAKE INTO
THISINE
O HAVEIKE GEGIALLY THEIR
LEADERSHIP ST
S
RUSSIAED
R.T
PREDICTION IS IT WILT
T WORK W
FOR E .
>> RIGHT
FO FRANKLYSTIT COMES TO PUT
CRTH JEWISH.
OW
COMPLETE TWIST OND IPLET A
THINK EXAMPL  I
SO CLOSED ALSSIANS.Y AND HE TWIO
BUT THE THE
HIS WA  NARRATIVEWAS CREATED
AS
DNSP OF
AND WHAT THIS NARRATIVE IS THER
TRUTH WITHUSOEW WOULD S
RORCURRENT IN HIS OWI MEANTH L
RESISTINWN RL ONVERGENCE,
HE TSTITH SORT
VERY SON0 S
WHAT HAPPENS IE 19s.HESTED IS T
HE'S FIGHTION THISNDTA
LCAUSE WHAT
HE'S DOING IS HE
T OFRITY
RUNS W
DOING THIS IS HE'SEM